[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas cette photo c'est non ce
n'est pas la bonne présentation
si les joies du direct
je vous assure ça fait pas partie du
speech ça donc à merci bonsoir à tous
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une question à partager avec vous
et si la responsabilité était une
émotion
certains d'entre vous ont vu le film va
vis et deviens oui pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas vu c'est l'histoire d'une
maman soudanaise avec trois petits
enfants qui pour fuir la guerre du
darfour se retrouve dans un camp de
réfugiés en plein coeur du sahel les
conditions de vie sont bien sûr très
très dur et deux de ses petits-enfants
décède alors imaginez vous venez de
perdre d'autres vos enfants et là vous
apprenez qu'il y a un programme dead
d'adoption qui est mis en place
votre dernier fils à cinq ans vous savez
qu'il a très peu de chance de survie
dans de telles conditions
que faites vous et bien pour sauver la
vie de son petit garçon cette maman
l'obligent à partir parce qu'il veut pas
sachant qu'elle ne le reverra jamais et
puis tout le reste du film en fait on
assiste à la ville ce petit garçon qui
donc adopté qui grandit qui devient un
homme et qui devient médecin alors je
vais pas vous raconter la fin du film
est d'abord pour ceux qui ne l'auraient
pas vu mais la dernière scène est
véritablement poignante moi elle m'a
bouleversé et à ce moment là précise je
repensais à ce qu'avait fait cette femme
et je me suis questionnée je me suis dit
mais est ce que cette femme s'est
sacrifié wasquehal était responsable
probablement les deux mais à ce moment
l'apprécié plus profond de moi je crois
que j'ai compris ce que c'était la
responsabilité et surtout du pouvoir
d'action que donnait le fait de se
sentir responsable vous voyez pour moi
se sentir responsable c'est se donner le
pouvoir d'agir
alors pour l'anecdote je me sentais
n'est tellement concernés par cet acte
responsable que je suis devenue marraine
des hommages de sa devise voyez je me
sentais mes privilégié d'avoir est senti
cette émotion parce que ça m'avait mise
dans l'action alors autant vous dire que
je savais qu'à partir de ce moment là me
sentir responsables allaient faire
partie de ma vie parce que j'avais
compris que ça donnait le pouvoir d'agir
et de créer de la valeur autour de soi
comme cette femme qui crée 2 fois la
ville alors j'ai avancer dans la vie
avec ce sentiment de se sentir concerné
et responsable c'est à dire pas un
hasard si mon entreprise se nomme me
concerne je crois que ça m'a beaucoup
aidé et notamment dans mes différents
postes de managers parce que finalement
être un manager et accompagner ses
collaborateurs à ce qu'ils se sentent
responsables pour qu'ils créent de la
valeur autour d'eux comme les exprime
pleinement leur potentiel de création de
valeur sûre en fait je crois que pour
chacun d'entre nous et bien se sentir
responsable c'est créer de la valeur
chaque jour 1 au petit au quotidien dans
des petits gestes et puis bien sûr son
plan professionnel alors cédric son plan
professionnel tout le monde parle de
valeur mais de quelles valeurs parlant
nous en c'est vrai que quand on pense au
business tout de suite on pense à la
valeur financière dans ce qui est quand
même plutôt normal c'est ce qui assure
la pérennité des entreprises et c'est ce
qui permet d'avoir un salaire pour les
employés
alors y en a un dans ce domaine je passe
ici que je trouve mais juste
impressionnant ce jeu pas si vous
connaissez c'est jim simons
j'ai une salle bonne c'est le patron de
renaissance technologies et son métier
c'est de gérer des fonds
d'investissement eh bien figurez vous
que j'ai vu dans un très bon au journal
forbes
en 2015 passage en 2015 d'une simons
avait perçu une rémunération de 1
milliard 500 millions d'euros c'est 4
millions d'euros par jour
ces 170 mille euros par heure bah
j'ai fait ces chiffres pour la première
fois avait quand même ça c'est de la
création de valeurs financières avec
chapeau bas mais vous voyez ce qui
serait intéressant de savoir surtout
pour pas tomber trop rapidement dans les
pièges idéologique c'est de se demander
quelle valeur créée jean simons pour la
société quelle valeur créée renaissance
technologies en la société comment cette
entreprise par exemple se saisit tel du
sujet de la protection de la nature
parce que la valeur
elle se mesure aussi en termes de
contribution qu'il y ait une valeur
financière art capturés par une
entreprise dans un service et introduit
ben c'est normal et il faut mettre cette
valeur au regard de la valeur créée et
créent de la valeur quand on est une
entreprise responsable et bien ça crée
de la valeur sociale sociétale
environnementale et économique
et vous voyez c'est l'ensemble de ces
valeurs qui donne du sens aux activités
des entreprises
alors après quand on voit les choses
sous cet angle il faut donc pas être
étonné que certaines personnes viennent
interpeller les dirigeants justement sur
leur capacité à créer de la valeur pour
la société
je sais pas dans quel domaine d'activité
vous travaillez si on est déjà venu vous
interpeller sur ces questions ouah c'est
sûr que pendant 26 ans dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique ont souvent on est venus
l'interpeller sur le comportement
socialement responsables de ces
entreprises
il y avait des gens ont même très très
proche de moi qui me disaient mais
nathalie comment fais tu pour travailler
dans des entreprises qui font du
business sur la santé des gens alors
c'est sûr que formulé comme ça bon il
fallait que j'arrive enfin quand même
mais je vais vous faire un aveu
bien sûr qu'un moment donné je me suis
questionné dans ma vie de femme un sur
ma place dans une industrie comme ça de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
regarde toutes les critiques pouvait lui
être faites et j'ai eu besoin de
comprendre
j'ai besoin de comprendre comment un
secteur d'activité aussi important que
celui ci pouvait se saisir de ce type de
question et c'est pour ça que je suis de
chercheurs et j'ai donc réalisé un
doctorat sur la responsabilité sociale
des entreprises du médicament savait ce
qu'on appelle communément la rse et au
delà de vouloir comprendre ce que
pouvait être la rse dans ce secteur
d'activité ce que je voulais comprendre
c'était comment cette responsabilité
sociale finalement elle pouvait émerger
dans les entreprises comment le prouver
concrètement se mettre en oeuvre c'est
comme ça qu'avec mon ancienne entreprise
jean selles j'ai pu travailler avec eux
sur un processus d'intégration d'enjeux
du développement durable au coeur du
modèle d'affaires alors je vous dis je
vais vous dire exactement ce que j'ai
appris sur la rse dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique
mais c'est d'abord traiter cette
question pour cette industrie
sliimy alors vraiment pas chose simple
c'est une industrie singulière elle
oeuvre pour la sorte et dire que la
société attend d'elle qu'il sorte des
villes alors l'impensable d'aucune autre
industriel et en plus quand elle
découvre un médicament il faut qu'elle
se débrouille de le rendre disponible à
tous les patients qui en ont besoin dans
le monde entier voyez il s'agit pas
d'aller choisir son petit segment de
clients alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que c'est justement parce que cet
industriel on le voit bien
elle porte une mission d'utilité
sociétale majeure que les gouvernements
et les états leur ont accordé la
possibilité de déposer des brevets la
protection intellectuelle etc pour sa
conscience sociale où on considère que
le brevet finalement c'est la base d'un
contrat social implicite qui lie les
entreprises avec la société
en somme la société dit pour me dis aux
industriels voilà l'été on a besoin de
vous pour découvrir des médicaments donc
on va vous protéger votre modèle
d'innovation va protéger vos molécules
pendant
vingt ans qu'est ce qui va vous
permettre d'avoir un retour sur
investissement mais en contrepartie de
ce privilège qu'on vous fait d'accord ce
qu'on attend de vous c'est que vous
investissiez dans la recherche pour
découvrir des médicaments qui vont
pallier des besoins médicaux non
couverts pathologie orphelines et
tropicales comprise
et puis que vous vous comportiez d'une
manière socialement responsable
alors est-ce que ce contrat a toujours
été respecté bon l'histoire montre à
travers quelques scandales sanitaires
que la réponse est plutôt non et c'est
vrai que pour avoir bien étudié le
secteur faut reconnaître qu'il ya une
période de ceux de son histoire où les
les choix on va dire dans la recherche
et l'orientation dans la recherche elle
était quand même davantage lié à une
recherche de rentabilité court terme
plutôt que d'engager de l'argent
notamment dans les pathologies
tropicales qui ont longtemps été
négligées puis c'est vrai que va dire
que la problématique d'accès au
traitement dans les pays à faible revenu
a fait l'objet de toujours de nombreuses
tensions entre les gouvernements et les
ondes et les industriels souvenez-vous
du célèbre procès de pretoria sur la
crosse trithérapie dans les pays du sud
c'est un procès car énormément car
l'image de l'industrie pharmaceutique
alors pour autant est-ce que cette
industrie finalement on n'a pas su tirer
les leçons de son passé
est-ce qu'elle a pas su remette sa
responsabilité sociétale au coeur de son
modèle et bien la réponse est plutôt oui
et en fait ça s'est passé à partir des
années 2000 c'est à dire le procès de
pretoria vraiment a été révélateur pour
ce secteur en raison d'une très prise de
conscience émotionnel de leur rôle
sociétal et les comportements commencé à
changer à partir de là alors
concrètement comment ça se passe en fait
l'industrie pharmaceutique se positionne
en tant que partenaires aux côtés des
états unis aux côtés des institutions
comme l' oms et le mot de partenaires il
est pas anodin il est important ce qu'il
faut pas oublier une chose c'est que la
responsabilité le droit pardon à la
santé il est sous la responsabilité des
états et donc le monde du privé
comme les industriels et bien qu'ils y
contribuer aux côtés dvd pour pouvoir
répondre à l'inutilité sociétale alors
concrètement comment elle fait et bien
l'adapt son modèle d'affaires en
fonction des situations financières et
sanitaires locales donc ils vont faire
des prix différentiel ils vont faire des
bandes médicaments ils vont parfois même
renoncer à leurs brevets pour pouvoir
laisser produire les médicaments à plus
faible coût
ils vont développer un grand nombre de
services comme la formation médicale
continue à des profils de santé vont
mettre des services pour assurer le bon
usage du médicament leur bonne
délivrance parfois même dans des coins
très retranché puis parfois même ils
vont même participé à la construction
des structures sanitaires pour assurer
une délivrance des soins dans des
conditions sanitaires les plus adaptée
possible et en fait ce changement de
comportement il a été vraiment noté dès
2016 à travers une étude dont je vous ai
mis les résultats en eau qui démontre
qu'entre 2000 et 2005 et bien
l'industrie pharmaceutique est venu en
aide à près de 539 millions de personnes
soit les deux tiers de la population
subsaharienne pour 4,4 milliards de
dollars investis et plus récemment l'
oms publiée en son rapport 2010 est
qu'aujourd'hui 63 % des personnes dits à
risque à risque de pathologies tropicale
bénéficie aujourd'hui d'un traitement
c'est un record ça n'avait jamais été
fait donc avons une vraiment une prise
de conscience du secteur avec une bonne
mise en route et se poser mille petites
photos aussi l'accès ce tome est de
style saxe est mise aussi c'est une pour
ceux qui sont intéressés c'est
intéressant d'aller voir leur site
c'est une fondation qui à partir des
années 2000 ont été créés pour justement
et bien surveiller contrôler qui aussi
aider un le secteur de l'industrie
pharmaceutique à se saisir de son rôle
sociétal sur toutes ces questions
donc elle regarde le
niveau d'engagement dans la recherche
etc et tous les services que des pois et
le dernier rapport et bien relate dans
une amélioration du secteur sur ces
sujets qui continuent hélas matures ils
m'ont alors les choses soient claires je
suis pas en train de vous faire
l'apologie de l'industrie pharmaceutique
mais c'est vrai que c'est une industrie
comme très fortement critiqué et que
quand les choses sont faites s'il faut
le dire aussi
paillé alors ce qui ne veut pas dire que
comme dans d'autres secteurs d'activité
ne doit pas continuer à s'améliorer sur
d'autres volets tard heures sa
responsabilité sociale notamment le
volet environnemental parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a envie de dire mans alors à
quand les blisters végétaux
quand c'est pas si simple que ça hein
parce qu'il faut quand même stabilisé
des molécules c'est pas si évident et
puis sur le on a envie de évidemment
parler des ruptures de stock qu'on a
tous vécu cet été
bon voilà je vais vous dire un truc tout
le monde sait ce qu'il faut faire voilà
après ça on va voir si l'entente entre
le gouvernement les industriels d'un
marché il faut relocaliser une partie de
la production sur le en europe en france
tout le monde sait ce qu'il faut faire
et ce volet social c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont faites pour
les collaborateurs
mais si vous me dites bon alors c'est
quoi l'écart de salaire entre les grands
patrons de la pharma et puis la moyenne
des salariés
je peux même pas vous donner de chiffres
parce que de toute façon c'est pas
transparent oui donc bon on voit bien
qu'il ya encore beaucoup de choses à
apprendre a progressé mais je dirais un
peu comme dans d'autres secteurs
d'activité mais mon propos était de dire
que dès lors vous voyez qu'un dirigeant
l'entreprise en dirigeant se saisit de
sa responsabilité sociétale et qu'elle
la place qui la place au coeur de son
modèle d'affaires
on voit bien en quoi il ya création de
valeur pour la société alors pour finir
j'ai envie de vous dire que ce soit pour
vous même ou que ce soit pour une
entreprise
regardons autour de nous regardons
autour de nous parce qu'il y a plein
alors plein d'opportunités de se sentir
responsable pourquoi je vous disais
parce que je crois vraiment que la
responsabilité c'est notre vrai pouvoir
elle donne le pouvoir d'agir et créer de
la valeur autour de soi pour une
entreprise ça donne du sens à ses
activités et pour nous mêmes
ça donne du sens à nos vies vous avez la
responsabilité finalement c'est comme le
ligand en biologie cellulaire la
broussaille et cette petite molécule qui
catalyse les systèmes enzymatiques bien
finalement la responsabilité c'est le
ligand de notre vie est le catalyseur
vie je vous souhaite
je vous souhaite vraiment du fond du
coeur de ressentir cette émotion que
j'ai pu avoir à la fin du film va vis et
deviens celle de se sentir concerné et
responsables dont je n'ai plus qu'une
chose à vous dire allez vive et et
devenez
[Applaudissements]